we have to be humble we really are in a  pre Galilean stage we don't know what we  were looking for any more than jela leo  did there is an instinct for freedom at  the core of human nature who inquire to  create fates has ordained that the men  who went to the moon to explore in peace  will stay on the moon to rest in peace  we believe we have one objective  conspire every single person in the  planet how can we reduce the distance  between each of those people and the  object will inspire them the project is  rooted in my experience as a war  photographer going from one side of the  frontline to the other and finding that  the fighters dreams hopes and nightmares  are far more similar and they are  different